Michael Knowles joins us now Michael
thanks a lot for coming on I'm really
struck by the statement from The [ __ ]
who runs that school who says that
you're against diversity but it seems
like you're arguing for diversity the
diversity of the sexes or am I missing
something what are you arguing the
lecture itself is arguing for diversity
of thought on campuses that's the very
reason that I was invited to give this
lecture chancellor agrawal is a disgrace
to higher education I woke up this
morning expecting an apology for being
assaulted during a lecture that I was
invited to give at the University of
Missouri instead I was smeared
baselessly as a bigot they referred to
my claim that men are not women as an
extreme view point and they tacitly are
permitting political violence to fester
on campus the message here is very clear
when that person assaulted me last night
we didn't know what it was I initially
thought it was paint I was told by many
people in the room that it was bleach
they later discovered that it was a non
toxic chemical that merely looked and
smelled like a toxic chemical that point
doesn't matter what matters is the
message that they were sending this was
a warning shot to conservatives on
colleges around the country that if you
don't shut up if you don't kowtow to
leftist orthodoxy you will be bullied
you will be shouted down you will be
physically intimidated and maybe next
time that substance will be a little
more dangerous a little more toxic it is
fascism as clear as fascism can be and
the university abandoned every one of
its conservative students and it
encouraged the agitators and it
encouraged the violence and we're really
complicit in this for fun and there's a
publicly funded University that takes
tax dollars our tax dollars and we don't
say anything about it and we should shut
we should shut it down immediately I
would say but I would also argue that
it's not just a conservative viewpoint I
mean there are many feminists who would
like to preserve acknowledgement of the
biological difference between men and
women there are a political biologists
who just take it as a matter of obvious
fact that what you said is true did you
say so this was an ironing well this is
the irony if they had let me give my
lecture last night it would have made
this very poor
when you say that there is no difference
between men and women this very
fashionable idea that has come into the
public consciousness in the last five
minutes you erase the category of women
you erase the category of women's sports
you erase these categories they're very
important to our civilization now why
did they scream why did they shout from
the very beginning the very first
sentence of my lecture they shouted me
down eventually they tried to physically
assault me it's because they have no
argument they have no way to win in the
battle of ideas so they're gonna bully
every person who does not agree with
their ridiculous ideological fantasies
and we need to fight back I was asked if
I'm gonna cancel the rest of my speaking
tour the college speaking tour just got
ten campuses longer we are not gonna let
them bully us good we are not gonna let
them intimidate us even if the
university is abandoned every one of its
conservative students so I mean you're
basically taking the Galileo position
here you're arguing for science in the
face of a hysterical mob that wants to
hurt you for saying it I may as well
have given the lecture that the sky is
blue I have given many campus speeches I
thought this one would be the most
innocuous I thought this would be the
driest it's a fact as plain as day it's
a scientific fact it is a social fact
that men are different from women but on
these campuses now where the students
have been totally dis served by their
parents raise them without any manners
and by their educators who raise them
without any education they now will not
tolerate any plain spoken common sense
viewpoints and they refuse to learn they
refuse to listen all they will do is use
the hecklers veto and when it comes down
to it they'll get violent and they will
threaten you with substances they will
threaten you with chemicals and they
will shut you up we should we should
shut these places down they're there
they're wrecking the country Michael
thank you very much I hope you keep
going thanks grab me Tucker